so Matt we have had to chat with you
before about assembler and the game that
you're writing so what we can look at
today we're going to write some basic
game logic and assembly language first
I'm going to show the basics of the CPU
from a programmers point of view so
let's invent a CPU it's going to have a
logic core and because we're programmers
we don't concern ourselves too much with
that what we do care about the registers
and registers are very tiny typically
four to eight bytes of storage inside
the CPU itself for the logic core to
operate on so it's imagine we've got a
register one a register two and we've
got the PC the PC is the program counter
and that stores the currently executing
line of code so if you imagine back to
your basic days we would have something
like 10 print hello 20 go to 10 so the
10 to 20 are the currently executing
lines of code and basic obviously base
it would have a software solution for
this but the principle applies the PC
would hold the 10 so the logic core
would fetch that line of code to execute
it would then advance the program
counter to 20 and then execute that line
of code but this go-to routine would
inject 10 back into the program counter
so the next line of code would then be
10 again so this logic core let's
imagine it's attached to some pseudo ROM
some Ram may be a graphics processor or
something along physical wires and this
is what we call the bus so the logical
can fetch memory values in and out of
bus when it initializes it's going to
immediately start executing code the
program characters could be initialized
to 0 at which points at ROM in our
pseudo memory map it's going to
immediately start executing code from
the top of ROM so let's write some
assembly we can interact with the other
two registers then so the first thing we
want to do is put some basic values in
these two so let's do a move command so
we've got address 0 which is the top of
ROM and this instruction is going to
move the literal value 8 into register
r1 so that's what that command would
look like next line of code let's
imagine these lines of code are 2 bytes
wide address number 2 we're going to
move the literal value 4 into register
r2 and then as a third line
address for we're going to add the two
together so we'll perform an AB command
we're going to add 8 and 4 together
which are in r1 and r2 so we add r1 and
r2 together and the result will be
stored in r2
so what's going to happen when the CPU
starts up it's going to initialize the
PC to 0 which is address 0 in the ROM
where our code is address 0 is going to
move the literal value 8 into register
r1 it's then going to advance the
program counter to 2 which is going to
move the literal value 4 into register
r2 then it's going to advance the
program counter to 4 and that's going to
add register 1 to register 2 it's going
to store the value into register 2 so we
would expect 12 and register 2 at this
point just like basic using the go to
Terman command you can jump the PC
around
so let's perform that out operation
again so on address 6 I'm going to jump
back up to address 4 and that's going to
perform the ID again so once this
instruction is completed is going to
jump to 6 and that is going to inject
address for into the PC so that the next
executing line of code is going to be
back to 4 again so we're going to again
add r1 to r2 which would give us 20 so
that would add what was still in r1 to
what was now in r2 after the last add
yes yes changes are explicit you tell
the CPU exactly what to do it's not
going to change these register values
outside of the code you've written here
this looks really good for you know the
basics of doing some sums and things now
how does this apply when you get into a
game and I can see this being a good
good way for adding up the scores but
yep certainly we are going to look at
some very basic platforming code so
we're going to have a pseudo player
that's awful
start a blank page let me first
translate this to 68000 assembler
actually that's what I was going to do
okay so the 68000 cpu which is in the
sega megadrive is slightly different to
the cpu we invented here it's got 18
registers which run from d0 to d7 for
the general-purpose registers those is
used for a lot of logic and arithmetic
we've also got a 0 to a 7 which are
address registers which we use for
accessing
parts of memory rom ram other
peripherals on the bus
68,000 logic core we've got d0 to d7
registers we've got the a 0 to a7
registers we've got the pc just like our
fake CPU and the status register here
the status register stores the state of
the CPU after the last operation
it'll have flags inside it called the
Zed flag and the carry flag the Zed flag
is used to determine if the result of
the last operation was zero so if we had
four in our 1/4 and r2 and subtracted
the two the result would be zero it
would then set the carry flag we can use
that to compare two numbers to see if
they're equivalent it's also got the
carry register which tells us if the
result of the last operation was a
positive number going negative so if we
had seven in our one we had a twelve in
our two and we subtracted r2 from r1 12
is greater than seven the result is
going to go negative is going to set
that carry flag and we can use that for
comparison so we can compare two numbers
and we can perform logic jump around to
different parts of code depending on the
state of the flags and the status
register ok so we're going to translate
our pseudo example here into real 68000
assembly so the first command the move 8
into register r1 will be a move and we
need to add the size of the operation
here and that can be a byte or word or a
long for simplicity sake I'm going to
use along a byte is eight bits a word is
sixteen bits and a long word is 32 bits
so we're going to move a long word worth
of data 32 bits it's going to be a
literal value 8 and we're going to use
these d registers which are the
general-purpose or rhythmic registers so
let's use d0 next line we're going to
move another long word literal for into
register d1 and add together we're going
to add 2 long words worth of data
register d0 to D 1 I've used long words
for simplicity a byte would only write
the 8 into the lower byte and this would
be whatever was last in the upper bytes
of that register if we were to write it
as a word we would get 0 8 into the
lower half of the Reg
and whatever was last used in the
register would be in the upper half but
I always really were working with long
words
so this register would contain zero zero
zero eight and the same goes for the add
operation we're going to add 32 bits of
data so the entire register is going to
be added with the entirety of another
register I'm going to type this back up
into the P bar and I'm going to show
this running in the debugger so we can
evaluate evaluate each step as it's
running and then we get to add to it
with some basic platform player logic
let's go some basic assembly language
then I've got environment setup for 68k
assembler for the Sega Megadrive which
includes a basic skeleton here the first
thing we do is we define the start and
the end of the rom file for including in
the header later we're going to include
the header file here and previously
explained that the pseudo CPU that we
made was going to start executing code
from address 0 for 68k it's very
slightly different the CPU is not going
to look for code when it starts up it's
going to look for this table in the
first 512 bytes of memory so the first
thing it's going to look for is the
address to initialize the stack value to
and this is the one we're interested in
here is the CPU entry point so it's
going to start executing code from the
address that it finds in this entry of
the table rather than immediately stream
address 0 so we can define a label here
a CPU entry point and then back in our
code file here we can start executing
code from here because this is a
debugger it's very slightly different to
a standard program we have to initialize
the connection to the debugger using
this subroutine but don't worry too much
about it so we can then start typing our
code out so our example before was to
move a long word literal ate into
register d0 we were then going to move a
long word little forward to register d1
and then we're going out of the two
together so add long word worth of data
d0 to D 1 and that should assemble and
we can fire that up then okay so let's
switch the DevKit on load up the
debugger and then we'll load our
executable we have done a video on the
dev kit for anyone who's interested or
just give people a kind of one sentence
on what this dev kit is it's a sega
mega-cd development kit which has a
Schnauzer
bored inside for 68 caitli bugging on
top of that it's got the Megadrive
daughterboard
on top of that it's got the mega-cd
daughterboard this is connected to the
back of the pc by a scuzzy cable to an
ISO card which can interact with the
debugger here we've got an old ms-dos
based debugger ready to debug code so
let's load the executable the first
thing we want to do is reset the CPU and
then we can bring up a source window
here ok so we can set a breakpoint on
the first line as f9 to go so that
executables now running on the debug kit
here
and it's showing us in real time the
results of that operation so we're on
this breakpoint here so the first
instruction was going to move the little
8 into register d0 so if we step we can
see the result of that operation here
the next line was going to move a little
4 into register d1 we can see the
results of that here and then we're
going to add the two together the d0
plus d1 and the result is going to be in
d1 so that gives us 12 in hexadecimal
here so that's all working if you didn't
use this literal word you might be just
overwriting some part of that memory
yeah you can write a long word a word or
a byte of data which will use the first
byte two mics or four bytes for the
register the same goes for add divide
multiply subtract etc you have to
specify how much of the registers you're
going to deal with that includes
wrapping so if you're doing a bike Tad's
255 would wrap around 2-0 if you're
doing a word size at 65 K we're at 64 K
would wrap around 2-0 again and it's not
useful all those things are useful in
certain circumstances on yes tis yes
because the smaller the operation the
faster it executes on the cpu so you can
do a lot of optimizations by doing bite
size operations instead of words or long
words okay so we're going to write some
basic platforming code imagine we've got
a player at a floor and he has a
positive X velocity and a positive Y
velocity so he is running and jumping
and we're going to handle the logic back
to move the player the first thing we
want to do is to designate some
registers for the player x and y
position so if we initialize the players
exposition as zero and to register d0 so
play it x cause we can initialize the
players y position zero and use d1 for
that and then we can initialize the
velocity values so in d2 let's store the
X velocity something like 16 into d2 so
player X velocity and we're going to
initialize the player Y velocity to
something positive because he's jumping
so 8 into d3 player Y velocity okay so
now we need a game loop so let's write a
label for the top of the game loop let's
call it player update and then we can
start moving the player using the
velocity so we would need to add players
X velocity to the players Beck's cause
so we're going to add D 2 to D 0 we're
going to add the players Y velocity the
player's y position so we're going to
add D 3 to d1 so then we're going to
loop back up to the player update start
so if we do a jump back to player ok
that's going to continue looping forever
so let's save and assemble that and see
it in action so this is a discreet bit
of code for handling where that player
is would that be right yes this is a
very tiny game loop which would handle
the velocity applying to the player x
and y position obviously stuff would
wrap around this for drawing the
character and all yeah there will be
extras here for the graphics once you've
calculated the players x and y position
you would send it to the sprocket x and
y position that's a subject for another
day though
ok so let's break on this line will run
again and then we can break here so
let's initialize d0 to the play x
position 0 will initialize the player Y
pulse to 0 we're then going to
initialize the place X velocity to 16
I'm going to initialize the Y velocity
to 8 and then we going to enter this
infinite loop here so we're going to add
the players X velocity to Z 0 I'm going
to add the players Y velocity to d1 and
I'm going to jump back up and I'm going
to continue doing this forever and the
loop would just basically make him move
it will make a move for
so he'll continue to move right he'll
continue to jump up so he's jet packing
these jet packing so let's add to it
let's define gravity we would use the
equate label and we'll have gravity as
something like 8 let's define the floor
height as something like 7 I haven't use
an odd number yet so in the player
update before we apply the Y velocity we
want to apply the gravity to it so we
can subtract long word it's a little so
we need the hash again gravity from the
player Y velocity here before we apply
it once the position has advanced we
want to check if we've hit the floor so
to do comparisons you want to watch the
status register to look at the last
state of the CPU for the last operation
so if we do the subtraction one number
from the other the status register will
have a flag in it to tell us whether
that number had become zero or had
become a negative number so you want to
compare the floor height with the
players current Y position if the result
of that comparison was a negative number
the player is below the floor so to do a
comparison we would compare the literal
floor height with the players Y position
D 1 and then we would jump to a separate
part of the code if that condition was
met so we do branch if greater than
there's also branch of less than this
BEQ branch of equal there's also
equivalents for unsigned numbers as well
so that's basically saying if this
certain thing is true then go to a
different bit of code yes exactly so we
start by comparing the floor height with
a d1 which in the background would
perform a subtraction operation but
without writing results when he
registers he would only set the flags in
the status register state say if the
result of that operation would have been
zero or would have gone negative and
then we can check those flags with the
bgt branch if greater than so that's
just going to check if the value for the
carry flag is 1 or 0 so branch is
greater than and then we jump to another
label so we'll call this
Flor and then we'll define that label
here above floor so we compare the floor
height with d1 if that was greater than
then we are above the floor and we're
going to skip this line of code we're
about to write and head straight to
above floor so if that condition was met
we are below the floor and in that case
we want to snapback the player's white
position to the floor height so we move
the floor height to the players Y
position which is d1 we also want to
null out the velocity because once we
hit the floor we don't want to carry on
going down so we reset that register to
player what Y velocity will be 0 in that
case
so let's assemble and run that and we
can step through it one at a time so
back in the debugger I've changed the
initial X&Y pause so he's already above
the floor for this demonstration so
let's run this then initialize the x
position to 8 we're going to initialize
the Y position to eight we've
initialized the X velocity to 16 and the
Y velocity to 8 so this time the first
thing I'm going to do is subtract
gravity from the player Y velocity so
that's and that's down to four
before we apply the X&Y velocity so add
D 2 to the 0 add D three to do one and
then we're going to check if we are
still above the floor so we're going to
compare the floor height to the new
white position and we're going to branch
if it's above the floor which it still
is so we skip straight to this line and
then we jump back up the player update
once again we subtract gravity from D 3
which sends it 0 which means we've hit
the apex of the jump we're going to add
the X velocity at the Y velocity compare
a four-syllable of the floor which we
still are once again we subtract gravity
to d3 and this now goes negative which
means we're past the apex of the jump
we're going to start applying downward
velocity instead of upward velocity so
once again apply the X velocity to the x
position the Y velocity to the light
position I'm going to start moving
downwards instead and we're going to
keep going until we are below the floor
here so the floor height was set to 7
the Y position is now zero so this
comparison is going to ring true branch
is greater than above the floor which
will fail there we go
so we are now below the floor we need to
snap back
cup to the floor height so we set the
full height into the Y position b1 and
then we know the player Y velocity we
don't want to carry on going down so the
Y velocity is now zero and then back at
the player update and then forever we
will always snap back up to that floor
height and we are always on the floor so
now he's still moving to the side but
he's just staying on the floor he is
just stay on the floor yes because
gravity's are basically clamping him to
the floor right yeah indeed from here on
it's not tricky to add things like
acceleration deceleration in air drag
things like that and once you start
getting into control pad input and stuff
like that that you can then apply the
acceleration to the current velocity and
then have basic pad inputs we've seen on
your game in the previous video that
you've got bouncing balls in it and is
that just an extension of this there's a
very basic physics engine in there which
is just an extension of all of this very
basic collision detection is just
comparison of numbers applying clamps or
bounce or restitution etc you can build
it all up like Lego blocks like this
just learn one thing at a time and if
somebody out there wants to learn this
kind of stuff and they obviously haven't
got the dev kit and all this old kit
lying around where would you suggest
they start to sort of learn these basic
bits and pieces you can do exactly the
same thing using an emulator and there
are some freeware assemblers out there
you just need a text editor assembler
and an emulation off you go some are
better than others find one with a
debugger built in obviously otherwise
you'll get a bit lost but all the
principles are essentially the same is
this whereas
what scuzzy is yeah it pronounced scuzzy
I didn't realize that it was such a
widespread terminology I thought I'd get
laughed up saying scuzzy so I said SCSI
but whatever Thank You Internet